first a hearty starter a bruschetta with
ricotta and succulent griddle courgettes
for my main I'm serving fragrant roasted
beetroot and Thyme risotto
[Music]
but I'll be in trouble with the kids if
I don't do it but
so I'm enlisting the help of my youngest
Tilly to rustle up an indulgent
chocolate and lime mousse with crushed
raspberries
so if you want to wrap the chocolate
start breaking up in Little Bits we're
going to make the most amazing white
chocolate mousse our first job is to
bring half of our cream up to the boil
so
is
that is double cream okay so that's
gonna make a really nice rich chocolate
mousse what's your favorite sort of
chocolate is it white melt dark
I love white and milk
I absolutely love milk chocolate
is it really here we go cream in
so that goes in there now you can see
what's happening straight away can't you
it's melting really quickly melting
really quickly so okay oh excuse me at
least your jumpers white so you won't
spot it yeah
in another Bowl add lime zest cold cream
and whisk until it forms soft peaks the
lime cuts the sort of richness of the
cream and that starts to make the
chocolate mousse taste a little bit
lighter
Zenith you're absolutely right next add
to the melted chocolate mixture
because I'm whisking it's just getting
lighter and lighter and lighter
have it all taste
nice yeah the line gives it a really
nice taste Tilly I need the rest for the
mousse
I need some for my tummy no come on
chocolate mousse into the fridge
our next job is to separate out three
egg whites this is where I need you at
your absolute best okay because to whip
those whites it's going to be really
tough so we'll take it in turns 30
seconds each okay you go first
10 seconds gone
come on silly 15 seconds gone
20 seconds gone come on you can do it 10
seconds to go
five four three two one and change
excellent hold the ball right
go no wave
[Music]
Matilda
you can't do that to me 30 seconds
that's the best way of whipping up egg
whites
still not very happy in there so
a contentious whipped egg whites will
make our mousse light and Airy and when
they've reached soft peaks we can gently
mix in our cooled white chocolate and
cream mixture
once the egg whites hit the cream yeah
the chocolate sets the egg whites keep
the cream nice and fluffy and you get
this nice light mousse in the bowl now I
need you to crush some raspberries
please with some fresh mint
[Music]
take your mousse
wow that looks really cool now look at
that down the bottom there now
delicious
in the door please our yummy white
chocolate mousse will take at least two
hours to set so we can crack on with our
Mediterranean inspired vegetarian
starter griddle courgette Ricotta and
mint bruschetta for this recipe you'll
need a griddle pan an essential piece of
kit for that char grill look
cut thick slices of chapata bread
drizzle birth size with olive oil
[Music]
season with a little salt and pepper
and griddle each side until toasted
then slice a couple of courgettes
diagonally into half a centimeter thick
pieces drizzle and coat in olive oil and
season with salt and pepper
sear on a smoking hot griddle pan in
batches until all the courgettes are bar
marked on both sides
next roughly chop mint leaves and
combine with creamy ricotta cheese
spread your toasty to your pasta with
dollops of minty Ricotta and top with
your seared courgette
super simple and super tasty
now we're going to make a delicious
beetroot risotto we need to get the
shallots
just slice them in half and then just
chop them like that okay okay now have
you ever made a risotto
shallots please into the pan for Daddy
add a Sprinkle of salt and pepper along
with a couple of crushed cloves of
garlic once you start cooking the
risotto it's really important to have
your stock
gently boiling away if we're adding cold
stock on top of the rice all the time it
just slows down the process
generally you cook a nice wide flat pan
if you cook in a deep pan all the rice
sort of Cooks at different temperatures
that's a vegetable stock
you can't have different
chicken stock I made that mistake once
putting beef stock in the vegetarian
soup
now I didn't Matilda
I'm positive I'm joking
throughout the time how nice is that
smell it smells delicious rice in that's
a bit of a different rice this is
Arborio rice it's a perfect rice for
risotto now it's really important to
sear
the rice if we were just to put the
stock in without sweating off the rice
it goes all starchy so keep on stirring
for Daddy
no flambe on the risotto
to go with our deep red beetroot theme
I'm adding red wine
followed by the first Ladle of stock to
get things started now we're off
[Music]
what's happening to the stock
is reducing down and the rice is sucking
it in that's right so the rice is
actually getting nice and plump
one of risotto is live when it's like
this now we can't stop cooking it we
have to cook it all the way okay ready
for the next Ladle I'm ready good girl
here we go Ladle in
so we have to make this for literally 20
25 minutes and we're nursing it all the
way
beetroots
pilton rub them a little bit of salt and
sugar yeah and a little bit of age but
vinegar in there roasted them I'm a
great
my parmesan
how's that Rice doing rice is doing good
no
no where you want to be now look at that
nice glossy textured rice so beetroot I
want you to put two thirds of the
beetroot in there for me saving one
third for the top
good sprinkle the parmesan in there for
me please all over
again and then we're just going to get
some nice butter in there
butter gives the risotto a really nice
gloss look at that beautiful
let that come down let it come down
first
all right get your spirit in there
enough Daddy
there you go good wonderful shaking
risotto should be like lava
just
flows out and then the rest of the
beetroot on top
[Music]
some extra virgin olive oil
I'll pick up the bruschetta you take
that to the table
okay
Let's Go Daddy
this is my ultimate vegetarian dinner
delicious courgette Ricotta and mint top
bruschetta
an anxious roasted beetroot and Thyme
risotto
and put an indulgent white chocolate and
lime mousse with fresh crushed
raspberries for dinner it's a mega Rich
teriyaki salmon with a buckwheat soba
noodle salad brimming with healthy
greens and I like aperol Spritz jelly
for dessert first job the teriyaki
marinade for the salmon silly
gonna help Daddy with a salmon please
right
Teriyaki delicious
sticky sweet salmon okay first of all
I'd like you
a little season on the salmon please
with salt and pepper thank you all right
I want you to slice the garlic one in
front two behind yep
oh oh get a bit faster in the old age
huh good girl
thank you right garlic in with the
ginger
so we're gonna make a marinade
okay do you know what a marinade is it's
what you coat something in that's right
so let's start off with
soy sauce three tablespoons one
good
do it this is rice wine also known as
mirin
one in
what that is that's maple syrup it's a
bit like pure gold
beautiful a little touch of olive oil
it smells really good I want you to rub
the salmon in the marinade if you can
get chance to do this the night before
the salmon actually changes color but
it's fine even with 10 or 15 minutes
before you start cooking it does the
ginger and garlic give it a different
taste
you know what it helps improve the taste
and we cook it I have this really nice
glaze on there okay right let's put that
in the fridge to marinade and we'll
start the jellies
to follow the teriyaki salmon a grown-up
light dessert Prosecco an aperol Spritz
jelly
start by soaking gelatine sheets in cold
water
poor Prosecco 100 milliliters of water
and caster sugar into the pan heat until
the sugar is dissolved then add your
gelatin sheets
leave the mix to cool top up with more
Prosecco and a dash of the Bittersweet
Italian aperol
[Music]
pour into tumblers over orange slices
and leave to set in the fridge
all the refreshment of a spritz in a
perfect jelly form
the Teriyaki Salmon's marinating time to
get on with the noodle and vitamin pack
veg and seed salad
noodles
now this color because they're made out
of Buckwheat okay and then we're gonna
drop them in
so nice and careful if you slide them
that way
and then you go like that in your hand
and I'll show you there and then look
hold them like that and drop them into
the pan okay got them yeah okay so hold
on tight off we go
nice do they take longer to cook than
normally
take literally five minutes now what are
they
sugar snap peas okay
really crunchy now
carrot
and kale
I'm going to show you a really quick way
of slicing carrot ribbons so you just
come down
um
that's right off you go there we go
nice big long ribbons
sugar snap peas in yeah okay into the
noodles
you've got two
oh thank you wake up daddy next kale now
you know how good that is for you right
yeah kale in right how are the ribbons
good oh that's nice
you okay if you like some salt and
pepper on your little bit count
ribbons go in
good girl I didn't forget any like you
did so excuse me and because we've
shaved them really thinly like this how
long do you think they're going to take
to cook
about a minute oh it looks so yummy it
does look yummy doesn't it now we're
gonna drain
the noodles
that is beautiful see how the cows what
happens if you cook um the vegetables
for too long would they just go a bit
hard they'll go soft and mushy okay
and then
we're gonna drop the noodles
in but now
I'm gonna make those noodles taste even
better I'd like you to put a little bit
of salt and pepper on there for me
please
next
I'm gonna put a dressing on there Ginger
goes in
I can smell that
I can count you
how nice is that
a multi-season salad isn't it colors no
um Sesame
oh yeah that's right sesame oil a touch
will sesame oil over
okay rice wine vinegar a little splash
okay
and then finally
and it will touch of soy sauce and let
you drizzle that in please
one little final
ingredient what's that seaweed whose
favorite is that Jack's Holly's and mine
slice it into strips
okay I'm gonna chop that
oh how is that good I want you to
sprinkle that on top of the noodles
and I'll squeeze the lemon juice
oh excuse me
it was I had a lemon shower today
sober noodle salad is ready now
we'll get on and cook the salmon
doesn't it
boom let's go
right pan nice and hot what did I show
you when you put fish in the pan which
way did you put in
puts it in and
skin down that's right and then there's
the pan there and you put it in there
and you lay away from you if you lay it
towards you what happens it will spit at
you it will Splash that's right so take
your time good girl
good girl
and the last one good girl very slicky
very slippy
it's not so fresh nice nice
a nice little bit of Ginger on there now
a little bit of garlic it smells of a
mixture of all the flavors
a nice color on the salmon
nice and crispy that's right
I mean I'd like you to pour the rest of
marinade over for me please
nice
okay
now the Santa's gonna glaze now
well done you're getting good at this
cooking stuff you know that would you
like to be a chef when you grow up yeah
really would like to have your own
restaurant one day I might have a bakery
a bakery me and Jack are planning on
opening one together and you do the
paninis and make the coffees and I do
the cakes and the cookies then it's
gonna have like scrambled eggs for
breakfast so you've already thought this
out yeah we were planning it the other
night and when we couldn't sleep and
who's gonna be the head chef and who's
gonna be the sous chef no we're not
gonna do that because we've both got
different rolls in it oh I see this is
well thought out yeah but there's We're
not gonna need anybody else apart from
me and him so no other people that was
nice sounds amazing
you get the spoon here like this okay
and just tilt the pan I'll tilt the pan
you glaze the salmon for me please
yeah
they my darling all right I'm ready
do you keep the ginger on top of it
what was your favorite type of salmon
when you were little
salmon fish cakes
oh I like those you like those
how does that look that looks delicious
I'd like you to carry that very
carefully over to the table okay and
I'll carry your noodles ready
let's go well done
so I'm fascinated with this restaurant
you and Jack are going to open yeah
this is my ultimate healthy dinner it's
fresh home-cooked and full of goodness